la chaîne d'état russe machine
propageant organe de propagande outil de
propagande puis guerre de l'information
est en cours
[Musique]
les idées révolutionnaires qui peuvent
demain changer le monde
diffusion des vidéos sur youtube qui
nous endorment alors que russie a tout d
est le plus grand réseau en ligne
aussi russia today
voilà je regarde art est la seule chaîne
que je regarde c'est russia today suis
très heureux de rejoindre l'équipe rtg à
bientôt sur rt
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes fiers et enthousiastes ert
réussi à atteindre de tels résultats
pourquoi n'avez vous pas bloquer rt sur
youtube
c'est une machine de propagande monsieur
walker